bonjour et bienvenue dans filet écho
pour un numéro spécial automobile à
l'occasion du Salon de l'Auto à Paris
les Yvelines sont le premier département
automobile de France avec les sièges de
nombreux constructeurs comme Renault PSA
Mercedes ou encore BMW mais il y a aussi
plusieurs PME qui se démarquent par leur
innovation il sera en question
l'automobile avec l'inauguration des
sièges d'Europe car France et
international au 25 ans
nous voici sur le stand de Valeo Group
International spécialisé dans
l'innovation et la recherche et dont le
pôle le système thermique est installé à
La Verrière Valeo c'est 72000 employés à
travers 28 pays une quarantaine de
centres de recherche et une vingtaine de
centres de développement Guillaume de
vauchelle bonjour bonjour vous êtes
directeur de la recherche et du
développement du groupe alors
parlez-nous un petit peu des innovations
que vous présentez pour ce Mondial 2012
on présente cette année sur ce salon un
concept qu'on appelle hybride pour tous
qui consiste à remplacer l'alternateur
que vous avez déjà sur votre véhicule
par une machine beaucoup plus puissante
travaillant sous 48 Volts ce qui permet
de récupérer de l'énergie dans les
phases de décélération mais également
d'apporter un couple supplémentaire une
puissance supplémentaire au moteur
thermique quand il en a besoin
c'est tout à fait important dans la
recherche qu'il y a de diminuer la
cylindrée des moteurs pour qu'il soit
plus économe c'est ce qu'on appelle le
dancing ça veut dire qu'on peut induire
de combien les émissions de CO2 alors le
système permet de réduire de 15% la
consommation de carburant est donc des
missions de CO2 mais surtout pour un
coût qui est au gramme de CO2 gagner 2
fois moins cher que une hybridation
traditionnelle donc ça veut dire c'est
une innovation que les
constructeurs en ce moment en discussion
avec l'ensemble des constructeurs du
monde entier
alors telle innovation vous disiez 10
000 personnes à travers le monde mais
surtout combien de temps de travail une
innovation comme celle-ci se planifie
sur 10 ans nous avons une feuille de
route actuellement nous imaginons les
innovations que nous mettrons sur le
marché en 2022 de manière étape par
étape à proposer toujours plus de
performance pour un coût qui est
acceptable
pour Valeo dans les Yvelines alors on
l'oublie souvent mais les systèmes
thermiques ces deux tiers de la
consommation de l'énergie d'un véhicule
et dans les dans les Yvelines il y a un
réservoir de compétences tout à fait
unique pour un constructeur automobile
ou un équipementier automobile comme
Valeo nous sommes déjà rentrés dans ce
qu'on appelle la guerre des talents et
nous nous localisons là où le les
compétences les hommes et les femmes qui
vont développer les produits du futur
sont disponibles et se sentent bien
c'est tout à fait le cas de la région
parisienne et plus particulièrement du
département des Yvelines quand on
développe une telle innovation est-ce
qu'il aussi penser à la protéger bien
sûr valeo est parmi les tous premiers
déposants de brevet en France et
systématiquement nous faisons ce qu'on
appelle des revues de brevet de manière
à ce que notre innovation puisse être
exploité par Valeo dans le monde entier
combien de brevets vous déposez chaque
année est-ce que ça peut se chiffrer
environ 600 familles de brevets famille
parce qu'évidemment chaque projet chaque
idée peut être protégée par plusieurs
brevets différents on le disait vous
êtes présent à travers 28 pays est-ce
qu'il y a encore des pays à conquérir
des marchés sur lesquels vous pourrez
vous installer
de mobilité partout dans le monde entier
et notamment en Asie les gens ont envie
de se déplacer donc en Europe cette
envie existe mais le nombre de véhicules
est déjà suffisant et partout il y a un
besoin de réduire la consommation et il
y a aussi un besoin pour toujours plus
de confort et de sécurité avec des
voitures toujours plus connectées avec
une interface machine toujours plus
agréable et toujours plus sûr
merci
on écoute ensemble le directeur France
du groupe
l'idée avant tout c'est de représenter
Audi sur l'ouest de Paris où nous
n'étions pas présents jusqu'à maintenant
et donc avec un bâtiment qui soit le
plus représentatif de la marque c'est ce
qu'on appelle le concept terminal qui a
été développé par un cabinet
d'architecte munichois et vous vous
retrouvez tout l'univers de la marque en
un seul endroit avec l'avant-gardiste la
sportivité et bien sûr le raffinement de
dit on va faire de cette concession
comme d'autres affaires en France un
lieu de découvert de la marque pour nos
clients un lieu où on se sent chez soi
où on se sent appartenir à la marque
comme dans une famille et donc on
profitera de l'occasion d'une affaire
comme celle-là pour présenter des
nouveaux modèles comme c'est le cas
actuellement avec le lancement la
nouvelle A3 qui sera présenté salon de
Paris mais également peut-être des
opérations avec des véhicules un peu
extraordinaires comme des véhicules de
sport ou des véhicules qu'on n'a pas
l'habitude de voir sur la route on est
sur un plan aujourd'hui d'environ 60
personnes qui seront qui travailleront
sur site donc une trentaine de
techniciens pour la partie après-vente
puis ensuite une partie administrative
et bien sûr les commerciaux pour toute
la partie vente de véhicules neufs et
d'occasion
aujourd'hui quand on cherche un endroit
pour s'installer dans l'automobile avec
une force visibilité qui soit cohérent
par rapport aux autres implantations que
nous avons un rappelons-nous que nous
sommes sur Paris 16 et à Montigny Vélizy
c'est bien au centre de tout ça il y a
un grand centre commercial il y a un
gros une grosse zone d'emploi c'est une
zone très dynamique ça convenait très
bien à la marketing
nous voici à présent avec Dominique
moquart président d'ADN concept bonjour
Alice c'est une PME installée à Montigny
qui emploie une trentaine de personnes
et vous présenter cette année sur le
salon un système qui permet d'ouvrir la
voiture avec son téléphone portable on
continue à faire des innovations c'est
de métiers et c'est toute la richesse
d'ADM concept depuis ces dernières
années comment fonctionne ce nouveau
système alors très simplement à partir
d'un téléphone portable que j'ai ici de
nouvelles générations qu'on appelle
aujourd'hui le NFC c'est-à-dire qu'on
est en train de dématérialiser ce que
vous faites avec un doigt pour faire un
code aujourd'hui grâce à ce lecteur vous
recevez en fin de compte un tag et ce
tag quand vous l'approchez d'un
récepteur vous avez l'ouverture des
portes et bien d'autres choses donc ce
système va permettre l'autopartage tout
à fait c'est la suite logique de ce que
nous avions fait sur les véhicules de
Nice de La Rochelle de Nancy où
maintenant toute la flotte que nous en
fait et que nous avions modifié avec des
intégrations longues plus de deux jours
il y a deux ans
quatre heures il y a un an il y a 6 mois
on mettait à peine deux heures pour
modifier les voitures et ce que je vais
vous présenter est une réalité parce que
en moins d'une demi-heure vous avez une
voiture qui est transformé agréée par
les constructeurs conservant sa garantie
et en transformer en autopartage pour
des entreprises pour des individuels et
pour des administrations comment ça se
passe concrètement par exemple je reçois
un code sur mon téléphone et je veux
aller prendre une voiture en autopartage
vous réservez une voiture un lieu bien
précis c'est-à-dire vous dites où vous
êtes on vous dit voilà quelle est la
voiture la plus proche partir de là vous
la réservez sur le web mais maintenant
que le web arrive sur le téléphone
portable vous pouvez la réserver sur
votre téléphone portable partir de là
vous avez une émission qui va
directement à la voiture qui est équipée
elle d'une carte SIM la voiture va vous
reconnaître
donc aujourd'hui nous avions des badges
que nous passions devant ce qu'on
appelle un lecteur de carte RFID et ce
badge va être remplacé progressivement
par effectivement ce téléphone alors en
ce moment nous avons fait un lecteur un
peu spécifique qui lit les deux parce
que comme on est dans une période de
transition pour faire fonctionner tout
ce qui existe ça permettra de
fonctionner soit avec le badge soit avec
le téléphone et là magie les portes
s'ouvrent alors les portes s'ouvrent
on a créé un petit coffre-fort qui se
trouve dans la voiture et on essayait de
chercher un emplacement qui était
suffisamment transversal et on s'est dit
le porte gobelet c'est magique et donc
dans notre gamme Magic for car on a
imaginé un gobelet plein d'électronique
qui permettra en fin de compte de donner
la clé à la personne qui aura réservé la
voiture mais normalement quand on
a une
fois que vous êtes alors comment ça
marche comment ça marche
il faut éviter qu'elle rayonne pour
éviter qu'elle rayonne il faut
l'enfermer dans ce qu'on appelle une
cage de Faraday et donc on la rend
inerte c'est à dire que quand Eva est
enfermé dans la boîte c'est comme si
elle était invisible et on va réussir
simplement à la réinitialiser quand on
va la sortir de la boîte au moment où
grâce au téléphone portable
cette boîte va s'ouvrir pour vous donner
la clé comme si c'est moi qui vous
donnais la clé quel est le marché à
conquérir pour ADEME concept plusieurs
milliers de voitures
et je dirais si on dépasse les
frontières c'est plusieurs millions je
dirais que là en plus ce qui est arrivé
c'est que c'est l'aboutissement d'une
réflexion qui dure déjà depuis un
certain temps dans ma tête qui était de
réunir des PME françaises autour d'un
centre à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines pour
réunir des hommes des femmes autour d'un
projet qui était de transformer les
métiers d'hier en métier de demain parce
que j'appelle la mécatronique ou la
plastronique et nous avons réuni à
montilieu Bretonneux en fin de compte
l'injection plastique l'usinage
l'électronique dans un même lieu que
nous a permis de faire un objet réduit
et des objets qui vont être de plus en
plus réduits pour l'ensemble
effectivement des des prospects que nous
avons merci beaucoup Dominique Moka on
vous souhaite un bon salon un bon
Mondial de l'Auto 2012
va aller automobile puisque on disait
les Yvelines et le premier département
automobile en France europe-cart France
et Europe car international viennent
d'inaugurer leur nouveau siège au Val
Saint-Quentin on regarde ensemble ce
reportage
au cœur du parc d'affaires du Val
Saint-Quentin à Voisins-le-Bretonneux
c'est le nouveau siège d'Europe car
France installé auparavant pendant plus
de 30 ans à Montigny 200 salariés ont
pris leur quartier depuis 6 mois d'avoir
un parc d'activités avec des espaces
verts et pour nous un changement qui
bénéfique par rapport à leurs étions par
avance avoir son siège dans les Yvelines
c'est être au plus proche des
constructeurs automobiles notamment
Renault et Peugeot Citroën mais aussi de
ses clients
que nous avons aussi un certain nombre
de clientèle et qui en soi PME PMI au
grand compte des clients à faire qui
sont aussi sur le bassin économiques qui
se développent une enseigne de taille
pour le promoteur Codic gestionnaire de
ce parc d'affaires le 251 a commencé ses
travaux en 2002 en mettant l'accent sur
les normes environnementales nous avons
commencé à acquérir les premiers biens
en 2000 et nous avons commencé à
construire les trois problématiments en
2002 sans financement en banc puisque
personne ne croyance est aventure
puisque que le concept du parc est un
peu un parc à anglo-saxonne tous les
bâtiments de cette phase répondent à la
RT 2012 donc nous sommes assez loin en
normand environnemental les bâtiments
ont tous une signature Bréham very good
donc encore des normes qui sont assez
élevées en Europe en tout 13 bâtiments
composeront à terme le val-saint-quentin
sont déjà installés Adidas Reebok Yazaki
Siemens ou encore bentler Automotive
livraison des derniers bâtiments prévus
en 2014
avant de se quitter quelques dates à
noter dans vos agendas la Cité des
Métiers de Trappes organise un atelier
mieux communiqué pour préparer par
exemple ces entretiens d'embauche les 16
et 23 octobre ainsi qu'un atelier
handicapé travail le 23 octobre enfin
pour finir cette initiative des chambres
de commerce qui organisent un concours à
travers la France pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs le principe est simple
réaliser une courte vidéo pour
promouvoir la création d'entreprise et
l'entrepreneuriat en général pour plus
d'informations rendez-vous sur le site
internet 500 000 et moi c'est terminé
pour ce filet qu'aux spécial Mondial de
l'Auto 2012 je vous donne rendez-vous le
26 octobre pour un nouveau numéro